este vídeo ha sido posible gracias al
surf shark vpn luego os doy más detalles
pero antes vamos con nuestra historia de
hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
nagorno karabaj es una de esas regiones
que no sabías ni que existía hasta hace
dos semanas de repente ahora está en
todos los medios de comunicación porque
es el escenario de la primera guerra
abierta entre dos estados que hemos
visto en mucho tiempo
[Música]
y en visual polític solemos hablar de
guerra asimétrica guerrillas o incluso
guerras civiles pero parecía que las
guerras abiertas entre los estados eran
cosa del pasado sin embargo desde el
domingo 27 de septiembre de 2020 hasta
el momento en el que hacemos este vídeo
la guerra entre armenia y azerbaiyán
cuenta con más de 6.000 muertos entre
ellos alrededor de 50 civiles
por supuesto que estos números podrían
llegar a ser más altos porque al menos
por ahora la guerra no ha terminado
existe un riesgo real de que terminamos
viendo limpiezas étnicas o incluso
genocidios pero cuál es el motivo de
esta guerra
[Música]
dudas razones el control de nagorno
karabaj hablamos de una región de 4.400
kilómetros cuadrados con alrededor de
150 mil habitantes oficialmente esta
región pertenece a azerbaiyán pero en
realidad casi toda la población es
étnicamente armenia y no os equivoquéis
no es la primera vez que ocurre algo así
en esta región la primera guerra de
nagorno karabaj estalló a finales de los
años 80 y se llevó por delante a más de
30.000 personas junto a más de un millón
de desplazados tanto armenios como
azeríes desde entonces las pequeñas
escaramuzas entre ambos ejércitos han
sido la tónica habitual
de hecho en 2016 ya hubo otro choque que
se llevó por delante a casi 200 soldados
de uno y otro bando y que tuvo a 15
víctimas civiles
[Música]
hablamos de un conflicto que se remonta
a décadas de historia y en el que las
grandes potencias ni siquiera saben a
qué lado apoyar por el momento el único
país que ha tomado partido es turquía
que apoya a los azeríes el viernes 9 de
octubre rusia sentó armenia azerbaiyán
para conseguir un alto el fuego pero
ahora más tarde los cañones azeríes
volvían a bombardear la capital de
nagorno karabaj que es una ciudad que se
llama esteban care muchos medios están
tratando esta guerra como si fuera una
invasión por parte de azerbaiyán sobre
territorios armenios pero la historia
real es mucho más compleja quien tiene
la razón bakú y ereván es muy difícil
tener una opinión en este caso pero en
este vídeo al menos os vamos a dar las
principales claves del conflicto
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
esta no es la primera vez que hablamos
de nagorno karabaj aquí en visual
político en abril de este mismo año os
contamos cómo parecía que armenia y
azerbaiyán podrían firmar un acuerdo de
paz esto ocurrió en la conferencia de
seguridad de múnich cuando el presidente
azerí ilham alíyev y el primer ministro
armenio nicole para xinjiang estuvieron
debatiendo en la misma sala y claramente
nos equivocamos la política
internacional es impredecible y nadie
tiene una bola de cristal en cualquier
caso hay que reconocer los errores y
precisamente por eso aquí va este vídeo
[Música]
porque la pregunta que hoy nos hacemos
es a quién va a apoyar rusia y a quién
va a apoyar
eeuu y la unión europea a quién va a
apoyar la otan y por qué ha estallado
esta guerra justo ahora y está pasando
exactamente en nagorno karabaj lo más
importante que quiere turquía en este
conflicto hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes antes tenemos que
hablar de otro tipo de ataques los
ataques en internet este año 2020 los
ciberataques se han vuelto cada vez más
comunes y todos podemos ser víctimas de
una ciber estafa de malware que se
instala en nuestro teléfono móvil al
entrar en una página web o cualquier
otro tipo de crimen y por eso cada vez
más gente está utilizando vtn para
navegar por internet vpn es como surf
shark vpn
[Música]
cursar que es una vpn fantástica por
muchas razones seguro que todos habréis
caído alguna vez en una de estas páginas
web de spam intentan estafarnos con
pop-up a este tipo de prácticas se les
llama phishing pues bien se usar tiene
una herramienta que se llama clic web y
que bloquea todos estos popup si todos
estos enlaces que pueden ser un
auténtico peligro pero no sólo eso con
una única cuenta de surf sar podéis
registrar todos los dispositivos que
queráis el móvil la tablet el portátil
no hay ningún límite de dispositivos
[Música]
y como siempre tenemos una oferta muy
especial para todos vosotros que seguir
visual político básicamente si utilizáis
el código político terminado en casa
tendréis un 83 por ciento de descuento
más tres meses extra completamente
gratis es más podéis probar surf shark
durante los primeros 30 días sin ningún
compromiso en la descripción
os dejo los detalles y ahora sí vamos a
ver un poco de historia una historia sin
héroes ya sé lo que os estaréis
preguntando todos quiénes son los buenos
en esta historia en principio es fácil
empatizar con armenia los armenios son
uno de los pueblos más maltratados de la
historia para que os hagáis una idea
durante la primera guerra mundial el
imperio otomano asesinó a más de dos
millones de armenios y todavía hoy día
turquía se niega a reconocer el
genocidio armenio
además armenia es una democracia con
todos sus problemas pero una democracia
y como nota curiosa es el primer país
cristiano de la historia
[Música]
y os preguntaréis y qué podemos decir de
azerbaiyán pues se trata de todo lo
contrario hablamos de una dictadura
corrupta como pocas el clásico país con
enormes reservas de gas cuyos beneficios
han ido directamente al bolsillo de las
élites eso explica que el dictador azerí
ilham alíyev sea una de las mayores
fortunas del mundo lo mejor que podemos
decir de este país es que al menos es
uno de los países más seculares del
mundo musulmán
sin embargo si pensabais que los aceros
son los villanos y que los armenios son
unas hermanitas de la caridad lamento
deciros que os equivocáis en esta
historia simplemente no hay buenos
veréis durante siglos la región de
nagorno karabaj estuvo poblada por
cristianos armenios y por musulmanes
chiítas azeríes así nos lo confirman
numerosos censos del siglo 19
por aquella época tanto armenia como
azerbaiyán eran parte del imperio ruso
sin embargo en el año 1918 estos dos
países se independizaron y adivinar lo
que ocurrió pues que entraron en guerra
una guerra que terminó con rusia
esta vez comunista volviendo a invadir
estos dos países de nuevo armenios y
acerías se vieron obligados a convivir
juntos bajo el manto protector de la
unión soviética
desde la época de stalin allá por el año
1923 nagorno karabaj pertenecía a la
república socialista de azerbaiyán por
qué pues porque así lo quiso stalin y a
ver quién era el que se atrevía a
llevarle la contraria
[Música]
sin embargo las cosas cambiaron en el
año 1988 en aquel momento los armenios
que vivían en nagorno karabaj a
aprovecharon las nuevas libertades
políticas que había puesto mikhaíl
gorbachov para hacer un voto en el
parlamento regional un voto en el que
pedían que la región dejara de ser parte
de azerbayán y pasará a formar parte de
la república de armenia los armenios que
vivían en esta zona se quejaban de que
el gobierno de bakú no permitía que
vieran televisión ni que recibieran
educación en armenia por su parte los
azeríes salieron a las calles de bakú a
protestar porque no estaban dispuestos a
ceder una región y los armenios en
yereván hicieron lo mismo así es como
estalló la guerra de nagorno karabaj
[Música]
una guerra que no termino hasta 1994 una
guerra que causó más de 30 mil bajas
incluidos montones de civiles y que se
saldó con más de un millón de
desplazados
atentos 850 mil azeríes que vivían en la
región se tuvieron que ir a otras partes
de azerbaiyán y 250.000 armenios que
vivían en azerbaiyán se tuvieron que
marchar armenia
en otras palabras hablamos de toda una
limpieza étnica que dejó heridas
imborrables en ambos bandos
y diréis quien ganó esta guerra pues
podríamos decir que el ganador fue
armenia aunque en a gordo karabaj es
oficialmente una región de azerbaiyán de
facto hablamos de la llamada república
de arzak un país donde la policía es
armenia la divisa que usan es la divisa
armenia y el idioma oficial es armenio
este lugar está tan controlado por
armenia que dos de los últimos
presidentes armenios han nacido en este
banquero que es la capital de la red
pública de arsa solo esto explica que
esta guerra no haya terminado nunca
nunca hubo un acuerdo de paz simplemente
se acordó un alto el fuego desde el año
1992 la osce ha intentado sentar a ambas
partes para negociar un acuerdo
territorial pero esta mesa de
negociación está presidida por francia
rusia y eeuu y todos estos son países
que tienen enormes diásporas armenias
así que azerbaiyán nunca ha estado
dispuesta a negociar la paz con ellos
mientras tanto armenia no sólo se quedó
con un amor no karabaj sino que además
conquistaron todos los territorios que
conectan esta región con armenia
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea hablamos del
20 por ciento del territorio de
azerbaiyán y pensad que hablamos de más
de 800 mil personas que han sido
expulsadas por la fuerza de la tierra
donde han vivido toda la vida todo esto
explica el odio anti armenio que
profesan en bakú odio que se traduce en
declaraciones como ésta nuestros
principales enemigos son los armenios
del mundo entero y los hipócritas y
políticos corruptos bajo su control el
jamal y jeff presidente de azerbaiyán y
como os podéis imaginar para la familia
líder el odio contra armenia se ha
convertido en una herramienta política
de primer orden es el antagonista
perfecto para justificar toda clase de
abusos de poder para que os hagáis una
idea personajes como kim kardashian son
considerados enemigos públicos en
azerbaiyán no sé si lo sabéis pero kim
kardashian es de origen armenio y para
la narrativa hacer y es una más de los
muchos armenios que difundan propaganda
allí donde van pensad que la mayor parte
de la población armenia vive fuera del
país hay más de 8 millones de armenios
viviendo en países como estados
rusia y estos días por armenia alimenta
la manía persecutoria de azerbaiyán
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque si
pensabais que armen ya está dispuesta a
negociar os equivocáis hasta la fecha
armenia solo está dispuesta a mantener
el status quo es decir mantener su
república de arzak limpia de hacer y es
más todas las regiones de alrededor por
ejemplo en el año 2007 los ministros de
asuntos exteriores de armenia y
azerbaiyán se sentaron a negociar en
madrid la capital de españa de ahí
salieron los llamados principios de
madrid
estos principios dicen que armenia
debería permitir el regreso de los
azeríes que vivían en nagorno y después
permitir que todos los habitantes de la
región incluidos los azeríes celebren un
referéndum de autodeterminación
referéndum que estaría vigilado por
fuerzas de seguridad internacionales
esto implicaría que armenia retirase sus
tropas y eso es algo que no aceptan en
yereván ni en el resto de la diáspora
armenia principalmente la asociación de
armenios en eeuu han rechazado estos
principios por considerarlos anti
democráticos
[Música]
en otras palabras que ninguno de los dos
países está dispuesto a ceder un
milímetro para llegar a la paz y por eso
hasta la fecha una gran potencia ha
decidido apoyar a ninguna de las dos
partes
ahora bien que ha cambiado desde
entonces pues lo que ha cambiado es la
economía
veréis en el año 1994 armenia y
azerbaiyán eran dos países igualmente
pobres podríamos decir que se
encontraban en una situación de duelo
mexicano es decir ambos países estaban
en un equilibrio de fuerzas y por tanto
decidieron aprobar un alto el fuego
desde entonces la economía de armenia ha
crecido más o menos al mismo ritmo que
el resto de países de la zona mientras
tanto la historia de azerbaiyán ha sido
completamente distinta en el año 1999
azerbayán descubrió algo que cambió su
autonomía para siempre
hablamos de los campos de gas de shah
deniz en el mar caspio uno de los
mayores yacimientos de gas natural del
mundo de repente el pib de azerbaiyán se
disparó fijaos en esta gráfica
[Aplausos]
[Música]
a día de hoy azerbaiyán prácticamente
cuadriplica el pib de armenia y toda
esta riqueza se traduce en ejército
desde que azerbayán se ha convertido en
una potencia gasística no han dejado de
firmar acuerdos de defensa con un montón
de países y eso incluye rusia israel y
turquía y en este momento es cuando en
bakú dijeron armenia te acuerdas de si
alto el fuego que aprobamos por no
seguir el duelo mexicano y el equilibrio
de fuerzas pues ahora te vas a enterar
[Música]
en nagorno karabaj los peores choques en
décadas matan a docenas de personas
estas noticias del año 2016 en ese
momento la guerra duró cinco días y se
saldó con 200 bajas o sea que azerbaiyán
tenía armas mucho más modernas los
armenios resistieron pensar que toda la
zona está controlada por tropas armenias
y que estas tropas están muy bien
entrenadas
[Música]
en otras palabras que azerbaiyán quiso
probar su superioridad sobre armenia y
descubrió que la guerra no es
simplemente una cuestión de dinero y
armamento y sino que se lo pregunten al
ejército saudí en yemen y de nuevo
parecía que existía cierto equilibrio de
fuerzas y os preguntaréis entonces qué
ha cambiado ahora pues atentos porque
para entenderlo tenemos que hacer las
maletas y viajar a otro país
el despertar del gigante otomano el 15
de julio del año 2016 será recordado
para siempre como la fecha del golpe de
estado fallido en turquía nos lo hemos
contado varias veces aquí en visual
político para el presidente turco recep
tayip erdogán este golpe de estado fue
una oportunidad dorada tradicionalmente
el ejército turco ha sido el principal
representante del kemalismo es decir
eran partidarios de una turquía secular
y occidental
erdogán sin embargo defendía y defiende
el lo contrario muchos definen su
ideología como el neo otomanismo es
decir una vuelta al imperio otomano una
especie de resurgir del nacionalismo
turco
[Música]
como os podéis imaginar para poder
llevar a cabo una política tan
expansionista es imprescindible tener al
ejército de tu lado y por eso tras el
golpe de estado erdogán cambia la
constitución y llevó a cabo políticas
como estas
perdón purga al ejército y el poder
judicial tras un golpe de estado fallido
y todo esto explica el giro que ha dado
la política turca desde el año 2016 para
que os hagáis una idea turquía está
atravesando por una crisis económica de
proporciones nacho vidal ya más en el
año 2013 el pib estaba en 951 mil
millones de dólares seis años más tarde
en 2019 están en 754 mil millones de
dólares sin embargo pese a que la
economía turca va de mal en peor
el ejército de erdogán está en todos los
frentes posibles atentos a este mapa
os presento la doctrina del mar y batán
la patria azul os vais a hartar de oírla
mencionar en los próximos meses
turquía quiere controlar todos los mares
de su alrededor el mar mediterráneo el
mar egeo y el mar negro esto explica que
los turcos estén tan presentes en la
guerra de libia y que hayan entrado en
confrontaciones con grecia pero no sólo
eso a turquía también le interesa
controlar el golfo pérsico y el mar
caspio y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
pero y por qué les interesa tanto
controlar estos mares en lugar de
controlar la economía pues dos razones
por un lado hablamos de pura retórica
nacionalista pero por el otro
independencia energética hasta hace poco
tanto el gas como el petróleo que
consumía turquia venía de dos
proveedores rusia e irán ambos países
han sido antagonistas tradicionales sin
embargo las cosas han empezado a cambiar
en el año 2019
aquí y azerbaiyán terminan de construir
el gasoducto tan up que traerá gas a
europa recordáis que os he dicho que el
neo otomanismo es una forma de etno
nacionalismo es decir el nacionalismo
turco no se basa en la religión ni en un
sistema político sino en una raza y en
una cultura comunes los azeríes son un
pueblo túrquico con una idioma una etnia
y una cultura muy similares a las de
turquía y por eso tanto al 10 como
erdogán se llevan tan bien en anteriores
vídeos visual políticos aprobamos de esa
industria militar turca que ha
resucitado gracias a erdogán ahora
turquía tiene sus propios lanzar misiles
armas láser y hasta sus propios drones
por ejemplo es muy conocido el bayraktar
de v2 pues bien uno de sus mayores
compradores es nada más y nada menos que
azerbaiyán
[Música]
turquía y azerbaiyán profundizan en su
cooperación en materia de industria
militar con un nuevo acuerdo bilateral
esta noticia es de mayo de 2020 para
estos momentos el ejército de azerbaiyán
ya estaba suplido por armamento turco
ruso e israelí y esto en bakú significa
una cosa por fin podemos ganar a los
armenios y no sólo lo pensaba a su
dictador y jamal jeff sino también el
propio pueblo a feliz
los manifestantes en azerbaiyán exigen
una guerra tras los enfrentamientos con
armenia por estas fechas algunos países
como canadá ya decidieron dejar de echar
leña al fuego y prohibieron las ventas
de armamento azerbayán mientras tanto
ankara ha estado en valent 'no a backup
para que os hagáis una idea el apoyo
turco al ejército azerí es tan evidente
que incluso en la web del ministerio de
defensa de azerbaiyán nos encontramos
fotos como esta pero ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando muchos turquía no es
el único país que ha vendido armas
azerbaiyán porque el apoyo turco es tan
importante en esta guerra pues para
entender esto tenemos que remontarnos
aún más en el tiempo y volver a hacer
las maletas atentos porque ahora empieza
una película de espías
[Música]
las alianzas imposibles siria año 2012
los rebeldes sirios se levantan contra
el dictador al asad muchos piden a
estados unidos que intervenga por
entonces el presidente era barack obama
y barack obama estaba harto de mandar al
ejército a combatir a guerras en oriente
medio'
así que en lugar de hacer grandes
movimientos militares optó por llamar a
los chicos de langley así es cómo la cia
creó el programa timber sycamore a día
de hoy este programa sigue estando
clasificado así que hay poca información
al respecto pero lo que sí sabemos es
que la cia estuvo comprando armas en el
mercado negro
donde en los balcanes qué tipo de armas
ak-47 es gafas de visión nocturna y
lanzagranadas estas armas sirvieron para
armar a muchos de estos grupos que
luchaban contra la sal por otra parte de
la cia estuvo entrenando a estos
combatientes
[Música]
y si ya sé lo que estáis pensando y
estáis en lo cierto muchos de estos
grupos eran organizaciones
cómo decirlo organizaciones de dudosa
condición aún no se sabe bien quiénes
exactamente han recibido esas armas y
ese entrenamiento de la cia pero no será
la primera vez que eeuu termina dando
armas a quienes luego serán sus enemigos
[Música]
conclusión que tan pronto como donald
trump puso un pie en la casa blanca
el programa till there sycamore fue
cancelado de la noche a la mañana
decenas de miles de guerrilleros sirios
con un entrenamiento militar de primera
clase se habían quedado sin el apoyo de
eeuu y aquí en este momento es cuando
entra turquía así es como nació el
ejército nacional sirio un grupo de
mercenarios al servicio de turquía
cobran entre 1500 y 2000 dólares al mes
y tienen derecho a pedir la ciudadanía
turca
recordáis que os decía que el ejército
de azerbaiyán está peor entrenado que el
de armenia pues ahora turquía ha podido
solucionar este problema se calcula que
en esta guerra de nagorno karabaj han
estado luchando entre 700 y 1000
mercenarios sirios a sueldo de turquía
por supuesto que erdogán niega todas
estas acusaciones pero noticias como
ésta hablan por sí solos una gorno
karabaj al menos tres combatientes
sirios asesinados por supuesto alguno
podrá decir que estos combatientes
sirios pasaban por ahí y dijeron han
dado una guerra en un país que no
conocemos vamos a combatir por ahí a ver
qué pasa pero qué queréis que os diga a
mí me parece más razonable pensar que
turquía les ha pagado para que luchen su
guerra así que tenemos por un lado a
azerbaiyán que tiene cuatro veces más
dinero que armenia grandes reservas de
gas y el apoyo incondicional de turquía
[Música]
y la pregunta que se estamos haciendo es
quien apoya armenia pues por el momento
nadie uno de sus posibles aliados sería
irán pero por el momento irán se ha
limitado a asegurar su frontera
colocando 200 tanques para evitar que la
guerra le salpique rusia es un aliado
tradicional de armenia de hecho tienen
una base militar en la ciudad de giumrí
con más de 3.000 soldados
armenia forma parte de la organización
del tratado de seguridad colectiva que
es algo así como la otan rusa en
principio si azerbaiyán atacar a armenia
rusia debería salir en su defensa pero
recordáis eso de que en nagorno karabaj
es oficialmente parte del territorio
azerí técnicamente azerbaiyán no ha
invadido ningún país simplemente está
intentando recuperar un territorio que
le pertenece y pensaréis pero este
cuando rusia es un país que respeta la
ley internacional no le interesa a putin
controlar el cáucaso pues sí claro que
le interesa pero desde hace varios años
moscú y bakú han cultivado muy buenas
relaciones os lo explicamos en visual
política hace dos años rusia y azerbayán
se necesitan mutuamente para poder
enviar el gas a europa además rusia
tiene varios problemas en el cáucaso
regiones como chechenia y daguestán son
un posible foco de terrorismo islámico y
lo último que quiere moscú es tener de
nuevo atentados islámicos en su propio
territorio si de repente rusia atacar a
azerbayán que es un país musulmán
bakú podría contraatacar
y qué pasa con la unión europea pues lo
cierto es que la unión europea necesita
el gas de azerbaiyán para reducir su
dependencia de rusia en otras palabras
que turquía es la única potencia que
quiere entrar en este conflicto y todo
esto explica el interés de moscú por
intentar negociar un alto el fuego lo
antes posible
arme
y azerbaiján acuerdan un alto el fuego
sin embargo como ya sabréis este alto el
fuego se ha acordado sin turquía y
erdogán ya ha dicho que esto era sólo
una tregua una tregua para que armenia
retirara todas sus tropas de labor no
calaba sin concesiones así que horas más
tarde de aprobar el alto el fuego los
cañones azeríes volvieron a lanzar
misiles contra este banquero
así que ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros creéis que rusia o la otan van
a terminar entrando en este conflicto
terminaremos viendo el fin definitivo de
esta guerra con un acuerdo de paz y lo
que es más importante qué opináis del
papel de turquía en este conflicto hasta
qué punto tienen responsabilidad sobre
lo que está ocurriendo en nagorno
karabaj o podeis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y antes de
terminar me gustaría dar las gracias a
yago rodríguez del canal cosas militares
por ayudarme en la investigación para
preparar este vídeo cosas militares es
un canal sobre política militar
ejércitos y armamento muy pero que muy
recomendable os dejo el link en la
descripción y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros a visual
políti y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]